covid19 exposed weaknesses in healthcare
systems across the eu
parliaments will vote on the new eu for
health program
which aims to support healthcare by
increasing the availability of medicines
improving disease prevention and
promoting well-being
recent terrorist attacks in europe have
targeted tolerance
freedom of expression and the right to
education
meps will debate how terrorism should be
tackled
parliament wants to prioritize the
economic recovery from the pandemic
and the climate crisis in next year's
budget meps also want to boost funding
for programs to support young people
research health workers and fundamental
rights
feta cheese champagne and parma ham
are just a few examples of europe's
specialities protected by geographical
indications
meps will vote on proposals to mutually
protect hundreds of european and chinese
products from imitations and misuse
parliament will elect a new vice
president to replace murray mcginnis
who became a european commissioner in
october